-You look gorgeous, as always. -Thank you.
-Thank you so much for coming back.
I'm always so happy to see you. -I'm so happy to see you.
-I have -- You brought us a very exclusive, very cool video,
by the way, which I'm -- -Oh, my gosh.
-I'm very excited about this. You were --
You were touring, and this is South America.
-In South America, yeah. -So, we're hiking,
and there's been a lot of spooky activity there.
Like, I'm talking UFO, like, alien activity.
And I'm not one of those people that's like --
I don't want to believe and then I see something
that isn't there. You know what I mean?
-Sure.
-Like, my parents do love UFO documentaries.
I'm like -- I'm okay --
Like, I am fascinated by, like, what's already on Earth.
Like, I love nature documentaries
like "Planet Earth," all that stuff.
I'm not super in the extraterrestrial.
So I'm coming from, like, a more skeptical --
like, skeptical mind. -Yeah.
-But we take this picture --
I'm taking a picture of my mom and dad.
And my dad is looking through the pictures,
and he sees these two objects, which we --
when we slowed the video down, there was three --
and it's -- Guys, I slowed the video down and everything.
It really -- I think that we might have caught a UFO.
And I was debating on showing the video here
because I don't want --
Like, if the aliens trusted me...
to be there at that moment, I really --
I don't want them to think I'm exploiting them right now.
-Yeah, yeah, okay, okay. I want the aliens to know,
this is just -- I asked for this, kind of.
I said, "Hey, can we have the video?"
This is all on -- -It's a safe place.
-Yeah. -And we're all safe.
-Jimmy Fallon. "The Tonight Show."
We love aliens from other planets.
-We welcome everybody, everything.
-Whatever you want to be called, yeah, exactly.
But we have this video of a UFO. -Guys --
-Watch this. Pay attention. -Guys, it's crazy.
-Now watch. -Did you guys see that?
-You see it? -Guys --
-Yeah, so here it is in slow motion.
Let's take another look at this. -I slowed this video down,
this picture down.
-Watch this. What is that? [ Audience oohs ]
-Guys, and there is another one that comes
from the left mountain to behind the other mountain.
-We actually -- We took a screen grab of it,
so if you can see -- -Guys, there's two!
-Look at that. -There's two.
That does not look like a bird.
It's not a phone thing because you see it clearly go
from behind the mountain to, like, close to the camera,
to behind another mountain.
Guys, I think that the aliens trusted me...
-Yes! --...to capture a UFO moment!
-So if anyone's out there listening to Camila right now,
we're -- we come in peace.
-Hey, maybe they trusted me because they're kind of like,
"She's kind of hard to get," because I'm not one of
those people that was super looking for it.
-Oh. -Do you know what I mean?
-So they convinced -- They wanted to convince you.
-Yeah, maybe they're like, "She's safe."
And now I'm talking about it on "Jimmy Fallon."
Like, I don't -- -No!
They won't -- They don't watch our show.
-Okay, yeah. -Yeah, they don't.
You're fine. -Yeah.
-Let's talk about "The Voice," okay? Congrats, by the way.
-I saw a UFO at "The Voice" too! I'm kidding.
-Nah. How is it working with Blake?
-Blake is so funny. I mean, I was just having --
asking you if you've had him on this show.
-Of course. -He's so funny. He's so fast.
I'm like, "You should do, like, just try out,
I don't know, like, a standup comedy set."
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah. -He's so funny.
Not like that's not, like, a really hard thing,
but I'm just saying, he's that funny.
Like, he makes me pee my pants of laughter on the show.
-Did you -- Did you have any idea he was going to announce --
-He's so funny? Oh. -No.
-Oh. -Announce that he's going to --
next season's his last season.
-I mean, he -- What is that?
Like, that's gotta be... -23.
-...like, 23 years of his life. -Yeah. Yeah.
-I mean, if there's ever a time to do something --
I mean, he's been on it for a really long time.
-He's done it for a long time. But he didn't hint at all?
-No, he didn't hint at all.
I mean, I definitely made fun of him a lot for --
'Cause he's always like, you know,
"I've won the shows how many times,
and you've won it no times." -Yeah.
-And I was like, "Well, it's like a game of probability.
If you're on the show 23 seasons..."
-Yeah, yeah. You're -- Yeah. -...you're gonna win a third."
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Camila Cabello in next week's episode of "The Voice."
Take a look at this.
-Good. -Wowza, wowza!
Guys, that was good.
-Thank you. -Thank you so much.
-I was, like, hot and flustered for a second there.
-Oh. Hey.
-That was a really sexy arrangement of the song.
-Well, it is my team. I mean --
-Hi, again. -I missed you.
-I missed you, too.
Okay. Jaden, your tone is to beautiful.
I want to hear it in my ear --
I'm just kidding. I'm joking.
I'm joking. I'm joking. That was a joke.
I want to hear it on a record.
I think you, as an artist,
like, as the whole package, it's special.
And you're my boyfriend.
-Before you go, we always play a fun little game
every time you're on the show and we do something silly.
-Can I ask you one question, though?
-Of course. -Wait. So when do you think --
When do you think you're gonna --
Like, when guys grow their beard like that...
-Oh, my God. What?
-Wait. When you grow your beard like that...
and then you shave it,
it must be like a big adrenaline rush, right?
'Cause it's like a full makeover.
Like, do you have any plans for, like --
No, like, I love it. -Plans for my beard shaving off?
-Yeah, I just feel like it must be so soothing.
Like, just to watch it all come --
-I wouldn't know. This is the first time
I've really grown a beard.
-Really? That you've grown it out that long?
-Yeah, it took me a long time for this.
Yeah, this is, like, a lot in the making.
There's a lot of glue involved. -What does your --
-Whoa. You got to take a video when you do shave it, though.
'Cause it must be like -- just like --
You must forget what your face looks like.
-Alright. Now you're embarrassing me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've just known you for so long.
-I know, I know. It's a different vibe.
-No, Jimmy, I love it. -You do like --
-No, I -- Guys, he looks great!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You look great. -Thank you. With my beard.
-I wanna -- Yeah. You should grow one.
-I should grow one. Yeah.
-I wanted to know if you want to play a new game
called SongMojis.
Here we go. This is it. -Okay.
-♪ Let me see those SongMojis ♪
♪ Baby ♪ -Here's how this works.
We're gonna be shown a string of emojis
that represent a song title.
The first person to hit this buzzer right here
with the correct title gets a point.
We'll play five rounds.
Each round is harder and harder and worth more points.
-Whoa. -You ready for this?
-Whoa. -Here we go.
Let's see our first SongMoji.
-I'm focused. -Oh.
-What?!
-Wait. Guys. There is actually a problem.
I can't see that far. -I have an advantage.
-I'm gonna have to come really close.
Should we both of us just come closer?
-Yeah, of course. -I'm sorry.
I actually can't see. -Before we come closer,
I'm gonna need to take points for that one.
It's "Watermelon Sugar."
-Okay. See? That's "Watermelon Sugar."
-It's Harry. [ Bell dings ]
-Okay. Now I can see. Sorry. Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Round two. This is harder. -'Kay.
Oh, uh, car -- drive -- "Drivers License"!
-Oh, my gosh. Hey! Nice. Nice.
-Now, I can see. -I'm rooting for you.
-I definitely need glasses.
-Here we go. Me too.
-Oh. "Walking on Sunshine."
-Gosh! Hold on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Hold on. Here we go. Next one.
-Airplane. Number one airplane!
-Ohh! "First Class," "First Class."
-"Number one airplane." -[ Laughs ]
-Alright. Here we go. Is this it?
Is this the final one?
-Uh. -Wait.
-Thumbs up. Good. Good. "A." A good prayer.
"Living on a Prayer." -Good letter.
-Good letter. Praying on a -- Thumb.
Up -- -Finger on the thumb.
-Yes. -"Shape of You."
-Yes and please.
-Yes -- -Yes and thank you.
-Wait. -Please and thank you.
-Good job. Good A. Good A.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Living what?! -What?!
-"Like a Prayer"! -"Like a Prayer"!
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-You pressed the buzzer. Camila Cabello, everybody.
"The Voice" airs Mondays and Tuesdays at 8:00 p.m.
here on NBC.
We'll be right back with standup from Ian Lara.
Stick around, everybody.